in this ever evolving landscape of
digital world cyber security remains a
Paramount concern as technology
continues to advance so do the threats
that look in the digital Shadows to
ensure the security resilience of a
digital infrastructure Professionals in
the field of cyber security must stay
ahead of the curve in this video on
cyber security roadmap 2024 we will walk
through the cyber security landscape for
2024 focusing on the learning path
prerequisites available job
opportunities salaries and the promising
future that awaits those who embark on
the jury in this video we will be
covering first of all the learning path
then pre-requirements when company
hiring and salary then the future score
but before we begin let me ask you a
quick question so what type of attack
involves a hacker eavesdropping on a
communication between two parties
without the knowledge option A is
phishing option b is man in the middle
option C is Ransom way and option D is
SQL injection now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below so in this video on cyber security
roadmap 2024 we will start with the
learning path so the first step to start
with cyber security journey is learn
Linux Linux is like Solid Ground on
which cyber Security Experts build their
Knowledge Learning Linux is essential as
it provides the foundation for
understanding the technical aspect of
cyber security you will gain Proficiency
in command line operations system
administration and file management
mastering Linux enables you to navigate
various security tools and perform tasks
efficiently it's the starting point for
anyone aspiring to be a cyber security
expert as it Fosters a deep
understanding of systems in our workings
and all these skills lay a foundation
for cyber security so after
understanding Linux your next step
should be networking networking forms
the foundation of the internet and plays
a vital role in cyber security it
involves how computers and devices
communicate and share information
imagine networking as the road system
term of the digital world connecting
various devices and allowing data to
flow between them at its core networking
revolves around two essential components
Mac addresses and IP addresses a MAC
address is unique identifier assigned to
each network interface card like a
physical address for your computer
meanwhile an IP that is Internet
Protocol address is like a digital
postal code for devices on a network
enabling them to locate and communicate
with each other understanding these
fundamentals is vital for cyber security
it allows you to spot irregularities in
data traffic identify potential threats
and Safeguard information Additionally
you will learn about network
architectures security models and tools
like firewalls intrusion detection
system all of which contribute to
creating a secure digital environment
third thing you can do is understanding
web so the internet is commonplace where
many cyber threats begin which is why
understanding web security is really
important in this part of learning path
we will look at things like HTTP https
HTML and JavaScript to see how websites
and web apps work we'll also talk about
some problems like SQL injections
cross-right scripting and cross-site
request forgery csrf that can make
Webster plus secure learning how to find
and fix these issues is a big deal for a
cyber security pro because it helps to
keep web apps safe when you get how
webtech works you can do a better job
stopping cyber attacks the target web
stuff you will also get to know about
HTTP requests HTTP responses and request
headers which are the building blocks of
how web communication happens all right
the next thing is practice yes to get
better at something you need to practice
to do this you can set up a home lab
where you can experiment with different
cyber security techniques in a safe
environment alternately you can use
online platforms like hack the Box try
hack me or virtual hacking Labs which
provide real world scenarios to test
your skills these practice sessions help
you learn more about cyber security and
develop your problem solving abilities
remember the more you practice the
better you become at keeping digital
information safe from cyber threats all
right now the next step would be
certification you can explore various
cyber security certifications you can
start your journey towards cyber
security expertise with the
post-graduate program in cyber security
by simply learn it is meticulously
designed to equip you with the skills
required in the rapidly growing field
dive into the real world scenarios
through industry case studies gain
practical experiences with over 25
Hands-On projects and access the highly
sought after ceh kit finish strong with
Capstone project spanning three crucial
domains and take the first step towards
elevating your career in the dynamic and
vital realm of cyber security and role
today to unlock your full potential also
to opt for this program following things
are required a bachelor's degree with an
average of 50 percent or higher marks
and the candidate may have known
programming background and the candidate
are not required to have Pride work
experience now you can also listen to
what our Learners has to say about the
course hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simple
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
I.T sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened on our
first all right now let's discuss the
pre requirements of a cyber security
roadmap so the first would be a
bachelor's degree a solid Educational
Foundation is crucial most individuals
start with bachelor's degree enough
related field like computer science
information technology or cyber security
this provides fundamental knowledge in
Computing and Technology Next Step would
be completing a certification start with
enrolling in a program like Advanced
executive program in cyber security and
you will open doors to a world of
expertise this comprehensive program in
partnership with tripleit Bangalore and
npci equips you with deep understanding
of defensive cyber security application
security malware analysis and ethical
hacking and more you'll gain practical
skills through Hands-On labs and a real
world case studies allowing you to
confidently tackle complex cyber threats
this qualification enhances your
career's prospects enabling you to spot
opportunities for disruption in the
cyber security industry stay ahead of
the curve and protect digital assets
with this Advanced programs key features
and Industry relevant knowledge Next
Step would be be updated the cyber
security landscape is constantly
evolving staying updated with the latest
threats Technologies and best practices
is essential engaging in continuous
learning through workshops seminar and
online courses and forums to remain
current in the field these prerequisites
form the foundation for a successful
cyber security roadmap they provide the
knowledge skills and credentials needed
to pursue a career in cyber security
effectively now let's have a look at
cyber security jobs and salaries cyber
Security Professionals have
opportunities across various sectors
including government Finance Health Care
education and entertainment some of the
popular job roles for cyber security
Engineers are First Security analyst the
role of a security architect or analyst
involves designing constructing and
maintaining an organization security
infrastructure they are also responsible
for formulating policies and procedures
to ensure compliance with security
standards and regulations on an average
security Architects earn an annual
salary of 151 000 the next is cyber
security manager cyber security managers
are leaders who supervise the cyber
security team and coordinate security
efforts within an organization the
responsibilities includes planning
implementing and accessing security
strategies and solutions cyber security
managers typically earn an annual salary
of 128 000 the next is cyber security
engineer cyber security engineer and
Technical experts tasked with developing
testing and deploying security systems
and tools for an organization they also
play a vital role in monitoring and
responding to security incidents and
threats the average annual salary for a
cyber security engineer is one hundred
and twenty seven thousand dollars next
is penetration and vulnerability tester
Professionals in this role perform
ethical hacking and vulnerability
assessments on an organization's Network
systems and applications they provide
recommendations and recommendation plans
to an hand security the average annual
salary for a penetration and
vulnerability tester is one hundred and
twenty thousand dollars then at last
there is security analyst security
analysts specialize in examining an
organization's security data and logs
they identify and Report security risks
and issues to help maintain a robust
security posture security analysts
typically earn an annual salary of one
hundred and seven thousand dollars so
these diverse cyber security rules offer
competitive salaries and opportunities
to make a significant impact in
safeguarding digital assets and
information now let's have a look at the
companies that are hiring for cyber
security jobs first Accenture Accenture
is a global Professional Services firm
offering cyber security Consulting and
solutions next is IBM multinational
technology and consulting company
providing cyber security products
services and research then there is
Cisco Cisco a worldwide leader in
networking and IIT Solutions offering
cyber security solutions for various
Industries the next is Microsoft
Technology giant with dedicated cyber
security teams protecting its products
and customers then there is Google
Global Tech companies specializing in
internet related services and products
maintaining a strong cyber security deal
then there is capgemini capgemini is a
global leader in Consulting technology
services and digital transformation they
are actively hiring cyber Security
Professionals for various rules then
there is HCl Technologies HCL technology
is a prominent I.T services and
consulting company with a global
presence currently seeking cyber
Security Experts to join the team this
increasing investment in cyber security
is a response to the growing number of
cyber threats that can harm businesses
and individuals alike hackers are
constantly finding new ways to access
sensitive data and cause disruptions as
a result companies and organizations are
making it a priority to fortify their
digital defenses so this was about the
cyber security roadmap 2024 by following
these step by a process that is the
learning path the P requirements the
company's hiring and salary
Etc you can move a step forward in your
cyber security Journey alright guys with
that we have come to the end of this
video If you like this video please give
it a thumbs up I hope it really helped
you all thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you